one thing I know that I am good at
though is calculating short lines uh cuz
I calculate them them well I'm good at
seeing little details and I'm also much
better than than most at U
evaluating uh which I think is something
that sets me apart from from others when
you say you're good at Short lines
what's that what's what's short that's
usually like lines of um two to four
moves each okay so that that's directly
applicable to even faster games like
Blitz chess and so on yeah um Blitz is
uh a lot about C calculating Force lines
so you can see pretty clearly that the
players who struggle at Blitz who are
great at classical are those who rely on
deep calculating ability cuz you simply
have don't have time for for that in
blit you have to calculate quickly and
rely a lot on intuition